ses fins
bonjour à tous je suis fait quoi le taq
taq aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
parité hommes femmes alors c'est quoi la
parité homme-femme
mardones sur le mont parité avec une
option suivante la parité et l'égalité
parfaite la parité est que chaque fête
et représentés à égalité
cette parité que ceux situés à
différents niveaux car si on peut parler
de la parité hommes femmes au niveau des
salaires c'est à dire que pour un
travail de valeur égale droite y avoir
égalité de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes y at-il toujours eu parité
parfaite entre les femmes et les hommes
malheureusement le lan si la devise de
la france liberté égalité fraternité
en effet la parité la palette est
parfaite pour de notre histoire ainsi
les femmes ont toujours eu le droit de
vote le droit de disposer de leur
salaire de 850 plusieurs lois ou fait en
sorte d'avancer vers cette parité depuis
1907 les femmes mariées peuvent disposer
librement de leurs salaires en 1944 les
femmes obtiennent le droit de vote et
des tribus
ce n'est qu'en 1946 que le préambule de
la constitution proclame que la loi
garantit à la femme tous les domaines
des droits égaux à ceux de l'homme
le principe de l'égalité de rémunération
entre les femmes et les hommes pour des
travaux de valeur égale aux gars que de
1972 ainsi depuis 200 ans la parité
entre les hommes et les femmes n'a cessé
de progresser mais de nombreux efforts
restent à accomplir
quels efforts doivent encore être
accomplis pour parvenir à une réelle
parité et d'efforts date encore être
fournis dans tous les domaines quelques
exemples alors que les femmes sont
proportionnellement plus nombreuses que
les hommes à accéder aux études
supérieures elles subissent davantage le
chômage et le temps partiel non choisi
l'écart de salaire c'est ainsi en leur
défaveur
au niveau politique on allait faire des
droits similaires
les femmes ne représentent 27 % des
députés et 1 5% des sénateurs
il faut tout de même signaler que ces
chiffres sont en progression de près de
10%
seulement 16% les maires sont les femmes
qui représentent pourtant 40% des
conseillers municipaux et en 2011
seulement 14 % les conseillers généraux
étaient des femmes
peu de femmes acceptent aussi aux plus
hautes fonctions de l'administration
publique des plus grandes entreprises il
ya donc encore beaucoup de travail à
réaliser pour que la parité soit
parfaite et ne perdons pas de vue que
les femmes représentent 51 25 % de la
population française
y at-il néanmoins des avancées
marquantes ces derniers temps
députés sénateurs a progressé de plus ou
moins 10 % - et il sait bien et a encore
raté les dernières élections
départementales ont marqué une étape
importante dans la parité politique
entre les femmes et les hommes en effet
depuis cette année les conseils
départementaux sont obligatoirement
composer de 50% de salles 50 % d'hommes
des lois peut faire avancer la parité ce
sont aussi les mentalités qu'il faut
faire évoluer
j'espère que vous avez compris ce qu'est
la parité hommes femmes à bientôt pour
un nouvel épisode